you say say russes j'espère vous allez
bien alors je fais jamais de making of
parce que je trouve que ça vaut pas le
coup de faire un making-of par exemple
sur un coup de fil mais là c'était une
vidéo particulièrement différentes
je parle de la vidéo de la semaine
dernière que je sortis s'appelle 21
jours au népal si vous l'avez pas vu l
avoir et je suis très bien ici
alors pourquoi j'ai fait cette vidéo
déjà en fait j'avais vraiment le besoin
la nécessité d'être seul
parce qu'on est toujours entouré de deux
genres de choses on est dans le flux
tout le temps et j'avais besoin d'un
petit peu de déconnecter de ça vous
savez quand on travaille seul ce qui est
mon cas et qu'on travaille pour soi ça
s'arrête jamais en fait c'est à dire
qu'il n'y a pas d'horaires de boulot on
pense jamais à soit pleinement qu'à soi
et je sentais que j'avais besoin de le
faire donc je les fais de manière assez
extrêmes c'est que je suis parti je
voulais aller dans une sorte de centre
de méditation j'ai vu qu'ils en avaient
plusieurs endroits du monde y en a
partout dans le monde mais il y en avait
à katmandou et pour le coup comme jolie
dans la vidéo katmandou ça sonnait bien
ça a l'air cool
donc je suis parti là-bas et je me suis
je peux pas faire un voyage comme ça
sans vous amener avec moi et c'était
aussi l'occasion de faire une vidéo qui
ce qui ne ressemble pas à ce que je fais
d'habitude parce qu'en fait une mais
frustration c'était que ben voila je
sais faire du montage c'est faire de la
prise de vue je sait raconter des
histoires enfin je pense en tout cas
j'en ai envie parfois j'ai envie de
jouer de le faire et je peux pas vous
montrer parce que ba un coup de fil ou
un pop up - seriously ou un masque c'est
génial j'adore vraiment j'adore ça mais
ça ne permet pas de vous montrer
d'autres choses que je peux pouvoir
faire et voilà je voulais vous montrer
cette phase est aussi de ma personnalité
et donc la vidéo c'était cette vidéo là
c'était le meilleur moyen de le faire
dont l'axé pour cette le fait après la
vidéo s'est affiné au fur et à mesure du
voyage
en fait je pense que ça se sent dans la
vidéo mais je sais pas forcément où je
vais je sais juste que j'ai envie de
vous montrer un truc et plus le temps
avance quand j'étais au népal et plus ça
prenait forme dans ma tête et donc
j'écris beaucoup pour voir quelle
histoire je raconte
ou est-ce que je vais et donc j'avais
cette piste avec mathilde rage avait
d'autres pistes si ça se faisait pas
ouais c'était assez intéressant simola
clapotis de l'eau voiture dans la ville
brûle tigres des bruitages très diverse
très variés mais je suis un
professionnel et j'étais super technique
nous a montré quelques-unes d'abord
l'orage très simple alors comment s'est
déroulé le voyage le voyage s'est
déroulé en deux temps clair d'ailleurs
il ya une dizaine de jours dans un
centre de méditation ou là pour le coup
je n'avais pas le droit ni de parler ni
de sortir on a pris tout mon matos
électronique c'était une expérience
assez forte mais du coup j'ai pas le
droit de filmer quoi que ce soit j'ai vu
un commentaire qui me qui me parlait du
fait que quand j étais forcément je
pensais à ma vidéo tard oui mais si
j'avais pas ma vidéo j'aurais pensé à
autre chose et tous ceux qui font ce
genre d'expérience il prend soin au
passé soit au futur espada en fait les
pensées viennent et partent chasser
comme des nuages
tu les regardes ça devient sa part c'est
le propre de l'esprit humain donc le but
ce n'est pas de lutter contre ça celle
observée plus tôt et en l'observant tu
te recentre mais pour le coup je suis
resté dû un jour de plus là bas pour
pouvoir prendre les images que j'ai
prises pendant la séquence
la séquence sur la méditation on voit ma
chambre on voit un bâtiment on voit de
quelques décors que j'ai filmé là bas et
les plantes drones au dessus de ce truc
là ensuite là où j'ai commencé à pouvoir
filmer c'est les dix jours qui ont suivi
parce que je restais en gros 21 22 jours
au népal et là j'étais à katmandou
ensuite j'ai voulu faire un tour sauf
qu'en vouloir faire mon tour je passais
par pokhara et là j'avais une petite
famille qui faisait du café et tout je
ne se poser chez eux et en fait j'ai pas
bougé et en pacte alors je voulais faire
un tour et je vais pas du tout fait pour
que je suis resté là bas et je suis donc
il y avait des décors magnifiques avec
cela et je suis revenu juste pour la
pleine lune est une fête religieuse sa
brigade jettera et donc ça c'est tout ce
qui à la fin à la fin de la vidéo
mais la question est ce que filme et m'a
gêné pendant que j'étais complètement
hors du centre la réponse je vais te
mentir c'est
parfois oui parfois pas t'as pas envie
de sortir ta caméra agen la faute sur un
trépied et marché quoi parce que tous
les plans où je marchais n'a pas
forcément envie de faire ça je n'ai pas
trop fait non plus tu vois j'ai su
m'accorder les moments j'avais besoin et
j'ai su m'accorder les moments où genre
il fallait travailler un minimum c'est
toujours cette voie moyenne
tu vois la modération un petit peu c'est
un principe qu'on retrouve je sois allé
chez les stoïciens ou dans la
philosophie du bouddha quoi oui
forcément ça m'a gêné un tout petit peu
parfois
mais au global n'ont globalement tout ce
qui est la faune et la flore par exemple
les insectes très simple les insectes et
moi savons hélas ça fonctionne alors au
niveau du matériel j'avais trois trucs
pour filmer principalement j'avais mon k
naan 6d j'avais le drone et j'avais je
pense l'appareil qui m'a le plus servi
de tout le voyage c'est un iphone 6,16
plus quand je l'aï acheté je me suis ça
coûte une blinde quand même et c'est un
moment où je voulais m'acheter une
caméra secondaire en plus j'en retire go
pro etc pour faire développe parce que
j'avais déjà un peu cette envie de
bloguer ne sais pas du tout un passement
produits pour apple
j'ai pas été rémunéré pour faire ce que
je veux dire tous les plans que je
prends dans un taxi ou dans le bus où
tout ça ça s'est pris avec l'iphone il
ya un stabilisateur optique donc ce qui
fait que que c'est fluide quoi ces
viseurs optiques que j'ai même pas dans
le réflexe donc ce qui fait que les
plans et à certains prague réflexe que
j'ai dû stabiliser en post production
avec différents outils et la mm pas eu
il ya même pas eu besoin
donc ça c'était mais mes 3 mai trois
trucs pour prendre de l'image et pour
prendre leçon
j'avais un zoom h4n qui et qui fait
toujours le taf qui est toujours là
quand il ya besoin donc
donc voilà c'était juste le petit point
matos pour cette vidéo je voulais que le
son soit fait exprès déjà pour des
raisons légales
j'essaie toujours dans mes vidéos
et ça sera de plus en plus le cas
utilisé que du contenu qui est soit
libre de droit soit qui m'appartient par
exemple dans le tout ce qui est dans les
salles au sli soit c'est ses couverts
par certains droits soit c'est des
images libres de droits bref ce genre de
trucs l'appareil cette vidéo je voulais
pas avoir de problème j'ai fait faire le
son et j'ai un pote donc clément qui
s'est mis à faire du son et c'est un
très bon pote et donc c'était facile de
travailler avec lui bonjour je m'appelle
clément je suis un pote de cyrus depuis
depuis cinq ans
l'époque où il avait des choses du coup
j'ai fait la musique de cette vidéo fait
un petit moment qu'on parlait de faire
de la musique ensemble
on a bossé sur sur quatre morceaux on a
bossé sur le morceau d'introduction de
montsouris l'introduction des vidéos
donc l'annoncé de son départ l aéroport
c'était vraiment une espèce
d'introduction
l'introduction à l'ambiance presque
sonores et des images très atmosphérique
en petite mélodie de canaux qui traduit
un petit peu l'évasion le voyage la
seconde
la seconde c'était une vidéo sur la
méditation donc en fait on a travaillé à
partir de sons que cyrus avait
directement enregistré là-bas notamment
le move et de portes de la ceni de
méditation sa propre respiration
donc voilà l'idée c'était de partir de
cession de base pour en faire des
percussions et pour qu'ils viennent à
couper et et voilà tout en rappelant
l'ambiance qui vient d'arriver en
morceaux et les images voilà c'était
vraiment faire écho à la vidéo par la
musique
ouais en fait ça le direct troisième
morceau c'est un petit peu entre le
premier et le second avec un peu plus de
rythme peut-être une ambiance un peu
plus loin tu es le plus joyeuse on va
dire qu'est ce qui a beaucoup fait
d'avoir trop doux pour la petite
histoire
et voilà on avait besoin de ce soir est
clair que la séquence finalement assez
courte
une quarantaine de secondes de musique
on a besoin de ça est vraiment droit au
but qui ont essayé dans les rythmiques
de rappeler un peu la musique
traditionnelle népalaise même dans les
sonorités c'est assez l'acoustique
finalement on va presser encore une
prescription en 40 secondes de musique
mais assez assez assez acoustique on va
dire que le quatrième morceau c'est le
c'est vraiment long trop c'est vraiment
une nappe
pour faire atterrir un petit peu genre
me dire qu'on décolle au début pour et
en intérêts à la fin simplement ces
jours-ci bout c'est la métaphore du réel
tout simplement à travers la vidéo et la
musique bat pour l'anecdote on fait de
cyrus m'a donné trois morceaux dans son
briefing envoyé un morceau de xxl
m'envoyait le générique indiana jones et
générique de star wars
voilà c'était c'était la base de cette
et la base du mollet froid donc voilà on
semblait complètement éloignées et on a
fait un truc radical on vous aime et
c'est pas plus mal je pense en fait pour
le montage c'est assez délicat parce que
vu que le montage est forcément basée
sur le son en tout cas moi je voulais le
faire et de cette manière là parfois ça
peut se faire de manière différente mais
moi je vais faire cette manière là nous
pourrons vraiment donner un rythme
j'avais besoin que lui termine leçon
avant que je fasse mon montage donc je
faisais parfois des pré montage en
lisant voile et les images elles
ressemblent à ça l'ambiance que je veux
donner c'est ça et lui faisait 1-1 des
boucles et donc je faisais mon montage à
partir de ça et après on a juste été un
petit peu et c'est donc c'était assez
hyper hyper intéressant hyper formateur
et ce qui est cool c'est que vu quelques
éléments on est très proches page et
passer des soirées chez lui et donc on
pouvait vraiment travailler l'un à côté
de l'autre et donc merci clément je
t'aime merci salut je suis chef
décorateur sur la vidéo de cyrus mars
on n'est pas au ils pensent que cyrus
nord c'est vraiment aller au népal et
plusieurs défis sur la vidéo déjà ça
pour avoir utilisé un drone expérience
folle j'adore piloter ce machin c'est
génial
le défi dans la vidéo c'était de ne pas
mettre trop de plantes drones pour pas
que ça fasse trop et regarde j'ai un
drone et voilà c'est facile c'est facile
cette belle image prend hargett franc
avec vous j'ai eu en fait toutes les
images de drones que j'avais je les ai
mises voilà le drone ça c'est difficile
de l'amener et d'en sortir parce que
d'un coup en fait mettre des images de
drones ça donne une autre
une autre qualité de production à votre
vidéo et genre d'un coup ça step up un
petit peu ça ça montre la vidéo quoi
alors mais qu'est ce qu'un
hélicoptère ont donc la difficulté c'est
de faire ça sans que ça fasse trop que
tu vois je peux pas faire ça au milieu
de plans tournés à l'iphone je pense
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça qu'au début
avant le plan de drones fuir un plan ou
en accéléré où ça monte un noir ou jeudi
et c'était fou et là je parle ans le
drone avec un changement de musique
parce que fall est une forme de rupture
quoi juste ici parce que ce n'est pas
des vraies personnes
c'est un petit cyrus et des petites
personnes sarrus ma plein jour mec moi
ce que tu as dans des petits modèles et
donc moi j'ai fait un petit cyrus en
plastique
c'était du bon travail je suis plutôt
fier de moi d'ailleurs à chaque fois
qu'il ya un plan de drones vous
remarquerez que la musique est
légèrement différente un peu plus
aérienne je voulais aussi ne pas être
chiant parce que voilà c'est une vidéo
d'un quart d'heure j'ai pas l'habitude
de faire des vidéos d'un quart d'heure
en fait le truc c'est que par exemple
j'avais plein de plans encore j'ai pas
mis parce que je me suis dit que c'est
pas forcément parce que tu as un beau
plan qu'il faut le mettre
s'il est en trop si ça rend pas dans
l'histoire si par exemple vous voyez le
moment où je me mets à il ya du drone et
je me mets un marché et qu'ensuite on
boit méditer et ses bas j'aurais pu
enfin on met encore plus mais est ce que
est ce que c'est utile est ce que ça
aurait pas fait trop en fait je préfère
frustrés les gens que les saouler voilà
je pense que l'importance quand on fait
ce genre de truc c'est savoir s'arrêter
pas mettre un truc juste parce que nous
sommes nous faits qui fait ou juste
parce qu'on trouve jolie mais est-ce que
ça sert mon propos est ce que ça sert
l'histoire qui est le plus important en
fait dans la vidéo je voulais aussi ne
pas faire trop gnangnan
parce que tout ce que je dis un moment
en voix off ses traits
amour tourner vers l'autre et c'est un
machin et moi je sais que j'étais dans
ma bulle
un petit peu quand je tenais pas et je
me suis dit ok les gens ils sont dans
leur vie de tous les jours et comprendre
ça dans la tête
est-ce qu'ils vont pas se dire mais
c'est qui ce mec là qui raconte question
raconte mec sort de ton délire quoi de
bisounours ou donc j'avais un peu peur
de ça et ouais vous voulez où vous
l'avez bien pris avec bienveillance et
tout donc merci pour ça je pense que 1
de truc qui m'a aidé aussi c'est de
mettre de l'humour dans la vidéo parce
que ça permettait de détendre un peu
l'atmosphère et ce côté je vous dis des
trucs sérieux mais je me prends pas au
sérieux non plus et en même temps les
vannes sont venus un peu naturellement
quoi ça me fait chier de faire une vidéo
ou qui moi même me fait pas sourire au
moins une fois quoi donc voilà je pense
que ça a aidé un petit peu à ça aussi
à la fin quand je suis dans l'est dans
les fêtes religieuses tout le son qui
est pris il est pris avec le live le
micro interne de ma caméra qui est un 6
d un canon 6 d donc le son est
absolument dégueulasse
alors en fait ce que j'ai fait pour que
le son soit pas trop dégueulasse non
plus c'est que et si vous ré écouter
vous rendrez compte j'ai pris un à
chaque fois dans les séquences une
séquence de son que j'ai traité
donc c'est vrai que j'ai gelé réduit ggd
j'ai mis des filtres etc de sorte que le
son soit plus agréable et je les répéter
en fait ça fait comme une boucle donc en
fait si vous écoutez bien à la fin
notamment sur tous les gadgets sera donc
la fête qui était en plein jour c'est
une boucle de son qui est la même pour
une séquence est la même pour une autre
séquence est donc je comprends ça se
voit pas et c'est pour ça aussi que ces
constats sont très courtes
parce que si c'était plus long ça aurait
été avec le son sort était vraiment
désagréable mais pour le coup la
séquence de nuit
elle sait pas un loupé c'est pas un loup
parce que j'avais pas enregistré assez
de temps pour avoir une marge de
manoeuvre et prendre un loupé donc une
boucle qui m'intéressait aussi pour
avoir le son le son qu'on entend un
genre au boeuf de réalité a été notre
âge et au delà qui est tombé patassé
était à la 7 voilà qui est équivalent
profonde et où je prépare les
enregistrer parce que comme je le dis on
je n'avais pas de matériel technique sur
moi du coup j'ai acheté le cdh et le cd
de discours de ce mec là et j'ai pris ce
passage-là du cd donc c'est pour ça
aussi que la qualité est plutôt bonne
hextadon comme sa seule chose que j'ai
trouvé pour pouvoir réussir vos fils ça
mais c'est le laissons que j'entendais
encore une fois jetée forme pas la
réalité mais je la mets en scène dernier
challenge limites et deux népalais
j'ai développé une technique assez
particulière mais très efficace
également concernant tout ce qu'est
méditation j'en ai pas beaucoup parler
dans la vidéo parce que je sais pas en
fait la vidéo c'est un mélange d un
mélange de beaucoup de choses à un
mélange entre un un blog un court
métrage une vidéo où je donne des
informations aussi sur le népal un petit
côté docu si en plus je faisais un focus
sur la méditation expliqué tout le
processus qui a derrière je sais pas je
pensais que ça faisait un peu trop et
j'avais peur de de faire d'eux de gâcher
un petit peu cette recette là parce que
j'étais déjà sur un truc un peu
expérimentale donc je vais pas faire
trop d'un coup mais en même temps c'est
aussi parce que j'ai eus trouvé le moyen
de l'exprimer ce truc-là via la scène en
fait je suis j'étais un festival qui
s'appelle frames à avignon où j'ai testé
sur scène donc j'ai fait une conférence
d'une heure qui s'appelle spinoza
epictète et bouddha entre dans un bar ou
bages explique en fait tout ce que j'ai
pas expliqué dans la vidéo c'est à dire
tout le processus intellectuel qui a eu
et qui mène à cette sérénité et c est ça
c'est un truc que j'ai envie de garder
exclusivement pour l'instant
ali rl c'est à dire à la scène parce que
je trouve que c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'en parler
en vrai vu que c'est de l'expérience
yale et c'est pas forcément
l'intellectuel et moi sur ma chaîne
j'essaie de faire des trucs qui sont
toujours très raisonnée vous voyez genre
par exemple seriously
je sais que soient le plus possible le
plus possible chiffré avec les chiffres
et c'est le coup de fil j'essaye
vraiment de
non seulement c'est même pas mes idées
c'est les idées des philosophes mais
j'essaie de faire ça de manière très
concrète quoi même si ça reste des
concepts ça suit un fil rouge et c'est
très mathématique finalement seyassah
donc à ça or on avait ça
ce qui fait ça voyez ce genre de truc
que j'aime bien quand c'est comme ça et
là pour le coup c'est très différent
c'est un truc est beaucoup plus dans
l'émotion dans l'expérience perso et je
trouve ça je trouve ça mieux d'en parler
en vrai donc je suis en train de
réfléchir à une sorte de spectacle ça
sera un spectacle en même temps drôle et
en même temps balance tout ce ce
discours là et j'espère vous apprendre
plein de trucs donc voilà je le ça fait
partie des trucs qui sont en projet de
faux que le test chez pas comment mais à
avignon ça s'est très bien passé j'ai eu
vraiment d'excellents retours
maintenant on va voir or ce qui est ce
qui s'en suit voilà je vous tiens au
courant ta sont sur les réseaux comme
d'hab avec beaucoup de gens mais ce
n'est pas une rue du népal non non non
c'est une rue de besançon et enfin il
pas important les retours de madine
draps
made in rats sa cagnotte ça va super
bien là d'un faux que j'ai regardé il
était à 3500 $ froid et il avait
commencé avant la vidéo il était à 700
dollars
donc vous êtes fou quoi merci ça défonce
merci pour lui la vidéo au niveau de ses
retombées à ailes basses et c'est juste
les meilleurs retours que j'ai jamais eu
la vidéo j'ai jamais une vidéo qui a été
autant partager à l'heure où je vous
parle elle a eu plus de 350 retweete je
crois sur twitter enfin c'est énorme
pour moi donc gros coeur comme ça merci
beaucoup
c'était vraiment un qui va faire
j'espère en refaire des comme ça c'est
des vidéos qui prennent beaucoup de
temps
coûte aussi parce qu'elle a tout le
voyage etc
donc voilà je sais pas quand est-ce que
je pourrais le refaire mais ça m'a fait
vachement qui fait de le faire et donc
voilà c'est ça se refera un petit mot
pour les petits peur je voulais vous
remercier spécialement clairement en
vendée les choses beaucoup plus faciles
donc je vous remercierai jamais assez de
soutenir mon projet global quoi ça va ça
va des salles roussely la vidéo vient de
sortir au temps passé sur certains coups
de fil pour apprendre des choses donc je
remercierai jamais assez pour ça on se
revoit la semaine prochaine devrait
maintenant c'est une vidéo par semaine
alors on en reparlera en parlera
justement la semaine prochaine mais la
semaine prochaine on se retrouve pour
une annonce que vous annoncez un truc
les projets de cette année donc voilà
j'espère que vous serez au rendez vous
et je vous envoie beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'amour pour bison et pressante